so if it's not dark mattera then what
else could it be Sabina Hassen Felder is
one of the most popular science
communicators on YouTube you can't spell
Sabina hossenfelder without the letters
n o BS she's beloved for her No Nonsense
no BS attitude towards science I never
had a chance to become an Olympic
swimmer is that fair and renowned for
her ability to simplify the world's most
challenging topics to educate Millions
across the world join us as we dive deep
into some of the biggest questions in
science today such as is the global
Mental Health crisis real well I was
trying to figure out if there really is
one how old is the universe really we
use the word Big Bang to mean three
different things and does Dark Matter
even
[Music]
[Applause]
exist welcome everybody to an
existential edition of the into the
impossible podcast with not only one of
my favorite human beings but your H
favorite human being by judging in the
comments section on Twitter and YouTube
it's uh Dr Sabina hassenfeld are joining
us all the way from boten boten or
someplace uh in Germany somewhere
heidleberg uh Savina how are you this
evening where you
are yeah I'm good it's about this a
thunderstorm about to come so you might
get to hear it and it's called bot B
back okay sorry yeah well yeah I'll get
you to pronounce some Spanish names of
of places in San Diego we'll see how it
goes Sabina you are always welcome on
the podcast we love hosting you and
having you and I uh we love watching
your videos and doing so many of the
cool things that you take us on uh your
adventures with uh with you but today is
a special day or it's commemorating
we're recording this because your second
book uh this book here existential
physics is now out in paperback which
for some reason they wait a year after a
hard cover comes out and they put out a
paperback that is the inciting incident
that is why we are talking today
although as I said I always love talking
to you so Sabina as you know in this
channel we always love to do the thing
you're forbidden by law to do which is
to judge a book by its cover but I would
like you to anyway nevertheless please
take the listeners and viewers through
through the process of this mesmerizing
books cover the title The subtitle and
the beautiful butterfly on the cover
I'll start by saying that the original
title that I picked for the book was
more than this was supposed to say
physics is so much more than what you
normally learn at school and you know
it's touching on all those big
existential uh questions but my editor
wanted to have the word pH physics right
in the title and so he came up with this
existential physics and I think it was
actually a really good decision um you
know though the the title that I picked
you know I have some personal feelings
about it but um objectively I think it
was the better choice and the the um the
butterfly this was actually my idea so I
made a little draft um you know kind of
a sketch where I had a
butterfly that was fading out
into dots and it was supposed to say the
butterfly is made up of particles uh
basically but it's also so much more
than this and so I insisted on keeping
the butterfly basically and also if you
if you looked at my first book uh lost
in mouth uh it has this very dark cover
with these confusing lines on top of it
and I I've always found this a little
bit
depressing so I wanted to have something
light something friendly and colorful
very good and the subtitle a scientist
guide to Life's biggest questions aren't
scientists supposed to stick to you know
the laboratory and the equations as a
famous scientist told me on Twitter we
need Specialists that was you well again
this was my editors doing uh it's
basically it's a summary of what's in
the book uh right so every every chapter
is a question and then I have my answers
when we confront kind of the Public's
appreciation of of science and the
relationship between what a scientist
does and what uh a lay person does as
they're called last week I got a lot of
vitriolic you know kind of hot takes on
my hot take you know I claim that you
know it's unusual that science needs
popularizers like Neil degrass Tyson and
you know Brian Cox and Brian Green and
Brian keading and Sabina Hassen Felder
because you know when you had like the
movie uh Barbie came out I'm sure you
saw it I saw it a couple times with my
girls um but you know the actors are
forced by contract to go out on the road
and talk about the movie and they
actually get training in public
relations and had a charm and Schoo and
I said why don't we have that done by
scientists and you said no it's not good
we should have people in the lab doing
what laboratory scientists do but I of
course go to your reference material so
I went to your book and I read the
following as the uh Steve Fuller claims
that academics use incomprehensible
terminology to keep insights sparse and
therefore more valuable as the American
journalist and Pulitzer Prize winner
Nicholas Kristoff complained academics
encode insights into turgid pros and as
a double protection against public
consumption this gobbledygook is
sometimes hidden in obscure journals I'm
going to do a mic drop now Sabina Sabina
who's right Sabina on Twitter last week
or Sabina in writing in this book what
do we have to F first of all this is the
origin of the word gobbley Goble that's
right in the in the title of my channel
name no I think this is a misunder
understanding what I said on Twitter
wasn't that no one should do it I said
it not all scientists should do that
it's not necessary and I think many of
them just aren't good at it or they
wouldn't want to do it like if every one
who wanted to go into science would be
forced to go out on you know some kind
of tour and Schoo with people we'd lose
a lot of good people because they're
just not interested in it and also I'm
not any good at
schmoozing I might be good at something
are you are you are one of the most in
demand speakers I see you on the I AI
Channel like every week I see you in the
in the media but I guess just as I do
with love and respect for you I I say
yes it is hard to do it but you you know
what so is calculating nuclear recoil
cross-sections or so is soldering a
balometer you know circuit these things
are not easy to do and actually I wasn't
born knowing how to compute fan diagrams
and they're not fun when you're doing
like 80 of them so I I would just push
back with respect to you and say you
know a lot of things that are hard are
worth doing only after the fact like
exercise and dieting and stuff right
those are hard things to do uh but my
point is merely that if we if we
relegate the cool script that Mother
Nature has given us the incredible magic
that's real as you talk about in this
book you know and your recent videos you
know then you're left with just this
class of people that just do
popularization and then our students
don't learn these valuable soft skills
and I guess I wanted to just ask you
about that you're not a professor but
you you've been in Academia you know
almost as long as I have and I want to
ask your your kind of uh thoughts on
what is Academia going to look like in a
few years how would you see the the role
of things like New Media like YouTube
channels like books and communication AI
chat GPT um avatars Multiverse metaverse
Savina tell me what are your thoughts
about the future of Education because
surely it's gone on you know for longer
than it should have in in its current
form what are your thoughts about the
future of education and Our obligation
to our students so what I was trying to
get at is that scientists at the moment
they're just they're just asked to do
too many things they're they to do
research they're supposed to do teaching
they're supposed to be to do mentoring
they're supposed to write grounds
they're supposed to review they're
supposed to organize workshops and the
you know things keep being added to the
list and it just it doesn't work and it
doesn't make any sense so what I what I
meant with uh my tweet is that I think
science communication is worthy Pursuit
that some scientists should do but it
shouldn't be something that should be
lumped onto the budget of everyone so um
maybe we should have some people who
don't teach but instead do uh science
communication why not take some of the
burden off of our current workload as
you do as I do yeah so I I wasn't saying
that we have to keep everything we're
doing now currently but by the way
Sabina you know if I I I only knew that
coid was over because I went to the you
know String Theory uh Department of my
uh of my physics department and I saw
the the strength the were not back to
work yet so that was how I knew that
that coid was over we had returned to
its pre-pandemic level of inactivity no
I mean some of these I mean
unfortunately I fight with my
theoretical friends you know it's even
harder for experimentalists because we
have to travel to these places we have
to build these experiments they're not
located we have to leave our hometown
you know theorist can so I always say a
theorist should Twi teach twice as much
as experimentalist and uh I get a lot of
punches to the face but but anyway I
wasn't suggesting that you just keep
adding stuff on more more than that just
to augment I mean Saina you you make
kind of light of it but you're an
excellent Communicator I don't know if
you've had training I I haven't really
had training I'm kind of thinking about
having more getting vocal training maybe
or how to interview people because I'm
not that great at it but you know you've
you've put effort into it and and it
shows and my only point is for my
students this is incredibly valuable
I've had students from China Thailand I
had a stu one student one of my best
friends now he's grad you know he's
graduated so now I can be friends with
pren sanasac he's got the longest name
of anyone he's a PhD now got is in my
laboratory worked on polar bear in Chile
and he could barely speak English when
he started UCSD I forced him I paid for
him to go to Toast Masters which is like
a speaking Club where you just go and
talk about like the weather you know
whatever it's not Technical and he
emerged a much better speaker so my only
point is we know better what skills are
going to be required when these uh when
these young people are older and I guess
my question to you is is it should it be
part of their education starting early
seems to me it would only be a good but
you know I I'll give you the last word
on this I'm not exactly sure what you're
what you're talking about now is it just
that everyone should learn English or is
it actually about you know how you
communicate complicated uh scientific
things everyone should have training as
part of some of their education where
they learn communicating not only for
their own benefit but the fact is the
public pays our salary you know we're
only talking because you know we were
paid by by the government and by our
home Nations to hopefully have some
return on investment and so not only do
I think it would be good for the
students eventually it's good for
science because if the public just feels
like oh you Eggheads don't care about me
they're going to say why are we giving
you know $20 billion doar to find water
on the Moon South Pole or whatever
anyway I'm asking you the the concrete
question is should it not should it or
should it not be part of their Science
Education along you know scientific
communication you know a basic a basic
understanding would probably be helpful
I mean you never know in what position
they'll end up in you know maybe they'll
end up being the president of the
University or something and you know you
were gonna be a YouTube star with a
million followers to I mean how could
you you couldn't have known that your
career took so many different paths and
changes and so forth yeah well so you
asked me did I have any particular
training the answer is no so I learned
everything by doing which you know I
like doing that kind of thing it is also
for the most part I learn physics you
know I have to do things you know give
me a paper I'll try to figure out what
they did in the paper that that's how it
works to me but when it comes to YouTube
I've actually been thinking about this
recently um it's a much bigger problem
because there's there basically isn't
anyone I can ask like who am I going to
ask right right yeah and and so it's
actually a little bit peculiar because
if you look at science writing like
written communication you know there are
associations and they have workshops and
they have books that you can read and
you know I read some of those books so
there's something that you can build on
and there are some uh seminars and you
can hire people to to train students but
when it comes to YouTube it's like you
have to ask someone else who does
YouTube that's basically the the only
thing you can
do yeah and so getting it to a system
and a team and and you work with a small
team but but um but it's uh but it's
hard yeah I mean I'm looking at you with
ill you'll have a million subscribers by
the time this comes out and you know
congratulations on that huge
accomplishment I also want to you know I
just love like teasing you but but one
of the you said oh it's uh so easy now I
thought it was so hard when I started
but now I realize it's so easy anybody
could do it Sabina come on you you have
um what's I have a book around here it's
called the unfair advantage and it's all
about these things of points of
privilege that that many of us have and
I I admit them I'm a 10-year full
professor
at a top research University that gives
me a lot of credibility to get guests on
my podcast like you and and so forth
I've written book you you have
tremendous gifts and you have tremendous
work ethic and I wonder you know if you
really were being serious or tongue and-
cheek about a a million for me right now
at
13,24 uh no nobody's counting uh but it
seems impossible it seems like it'll
never happen and I'm happy I'm content
with that little plaque in the back
that's silver you're going to get a d
what a diamond one a gold one anyway
Sabina are you serious is it something
anybody can do even a schmuck like me so
first of all I have a video coming up on
how you can get get to one million
subscribers but I would you know I would
really like to say a lot of it is
organization and what you're willing to
do like you have to be willing to cater
to your audience you have to you have to
try and figure out what people want and
then try to produce that content and
it's really a question of is this really
something that you want like as you say
you you're a professor this is not the
reason I'm talking to you but we both
know this and and so maybe you just have
other goals right you have certain
interests that you want to communicate
and growing your channel to a large size
is not the only thing you can do on
YouTube you know you you can you have
can have a specialist interest group uh
and keep that community alive and make
maybe attracting a huge number of people
it just isn't what you want there there
are many things that I could think of
that I could do on my channel that would
probably get me many more subscribers
but it's not a it's not a path that I
want to go down how do you balance the
many responsibilities and interest and
family and stuff how do you find that
balance the work life balance I mean
you're talking to me it's what 5 or 6 PM
there your your workday is still going
on right so how do you balance it how do
you um Outsource do you get help from a
team um what's your kind of goal to deal
with uh overwhelm because you put out
two pieces of content video content a
week you put out a newsletter that I
subscribe to you put out multiple books
in multiple formats you speak in
multiple conferences and and other
people's channels do you have a workflow
do you have any kind of advice to say
somebody who's just starting out of
which there are many many people
starting out in this field and want to
be science YouTubers and so forth so
what what's your advice U to kind of
avoid burnout as you do yes that's a
very good point so first of all it's
half past
7 and uh normally I don't do podcast
that late at night so I make an
exception for you but no seriously
normally I say no to that kind of thing
because I I want to have some kind of uh
private life which I'm really weird
about but I feel it's really necessary
for my mental health so to speak uh
honestly at the moment uh my work life
balance is not working all that well
it's partly because there have been some
people who have been dropping out when I
didn't expect it and so you know if
someone isn't available when they should
be then in the end it's always me who
has to get things done sooner or later
I'll have to find a different way to
arrange it but at the moment uh what
we're doing is we have a um very well
organized workflow that includes about
10 people and that we have a task list
that we we check off every week because
it's happened over and over again that
we forgot one thing and then other
things didn't work out and and so you
know we stood up late at night and tried
to fix things um it's partly somewhat of
a self-generated problem because I mean
it's not like anyone is forcing me to do
two videos a week um but once you've
kind of arranged it with the agency and
with the sponsors there expecting the
videos to appear not necessarily at a
particular date and time but within a
certain time frame so um some of that
flexibility that you have as you being
one person who puts out a video every
once in a while it gets lost and so I
guess part of the reason I get it done
is just that I've always been very
organized it's my German G genes I
suppose uh and so I mean you know right
you you been to workshops that I've
organized I so met it's just exactly so
it's the kind of thing that comes to me
naturally um keeping track of how things
are going uh and and I guess you know
I'm trying to make the best of it you
might think we know everything there is
to know about matter but we actually
don't know if matter and antimatter are
exactly identical however the media
landscape is fragmented making it hard
to find Reliable information for
scientists and even more so for Lay
people that's where ground news comes in
ground news is an app and a website that
gathers all the world's media into one
place so readers can compare coverage
and see the full picture of what's being
reported worldwide and on ground news
scientists recently found that
antimatter is subject to gravity as well
and there are 23 articles you can find
about this on ground news it's just
fantastic and it's fascinating to see
how ground news ranks them in terms of
factuality how they might lean ically or
what types of media sources they're
coming from it's really fascinating
almost as fascinating as the subject of
antimatter itself the app is delightful
it's Visual and it's enticing you can
adjust your addition using the app to
see news that's most relevant to you by
following topics you care about the most
whether it's science artificial
intelligence space Etc with the ground
news app and website you can read watch
and share the best information available
which makes following the news easier
and more enjoyable go to ground. newws
drbryan to stay informed on breaking
news scientific media coverage and avoid
bias And subscribe with my link for 30%
off on limited access it is essential if
you support the mission of scientific
literacy as I do now back to our episode
with Sabina Hassen Felder when uh we can
pivot away from you know kind of the
soft uh conver softer side of our
conversation but I I am really
interested in getting your insights into
education you're you are not a professor
but I think you've you know probably
educated more people around the world
than than I have and and many you know
full tenured professors um and I know
that that would have been a great you
know career up you know in the mult in
the uh in the everan you know many
worlds uh branch that we don't live on
but that you would have been an
outstanding professor and I would love
to have had you as a teacher and I I
learn a lot from you but what what do
you think about education Sabina what do
you think not just for the you know
graduate advanced level but at the
undergraduate level it's largely
unchanged from the first University in
Northern Italy in the year 1080 you know
some dude scratching on a rock with
another piece of rock you know on a
chalkboard or doing whatever except back
then S I don't know if you knew this but
the students didn't like the professor
the students would go on strike and the
professor wouldn't get paid so thank God
that barbaric tradition has ended but
what do you make of of the kind of
threats to Academia and maybe the the
opportunities things like avatars AI Etc
what do you make of of education is it
okay am I am I off base here or do you
think education at the undergraduate
level needs to be reformed in any way I
agree that education is like super
important because basically the the only
reason that human civilization got to
this point is because we're really good
at handing on knowledge to the Next
Generation Um so uh this is not
something that we should neglect I
really think that schools and higher
education are um much more important for
for civilization than most people
appreciate I personally I think that
like this personal contact that we have
with uh professors and so on is still
necessary um you know if you do
everything
online with huge classes and automate
everything you're losing a lot of people
because they really need this personal
contact and you know it's it's not as
simple as just saying well I record my
classes and then put it on uh I don't
know YouTube or some other platform and
then people can check off their multiple
choice test or whatever and that's
that's the end of it I think that just
won't work it's like the human brain
just wasn't meant to learn that way yeah
I mean I'm looking at opportunities for
you know for growth both and and I've
actually been involved with a team here
at UCSD that's making virtual reality
avatars right now just on a computer
screen and we've currently started just
with Gandhi and Fineman uh but the idea
is that we have a picture you know a
video of of an interactive person you
would have a microphone and and there
would be a speaker and you'd come up and
say you know they digitized we digitized
all of Fan's work and I put it on and we
made something called a fine bot right
now it's just text you can only text to
the person to the avatar called him a
person and fine bot will be animated
Richard Fineman eventually and my voice
will be transcribed then it will be
uploaded to chat GPT then it will be
rendered as if he's talking and saying
you know his answer and it will come out
in his voice because we can speech
synthesize his voice and it just makes
me think you know why learn you know um
you know relativistic quantum mechanics
from Brian keting or you know I won't
say Sabina Hassen Phil but I'll say from
Brian keing why learn um you know a
basic astronomy when you could have
Galileo and Galileo's words I have
access to I don't have his voice nobody
does but we have uh we have access to a
million of his written words and his
thought process he was an ex excellent
uh educator so why not have this um and
basically you know shortcut the first
couple years of undergraduate education
with the best teachers around the world
including maybe you know people like you
and me anyway that's that's our goal is
we're trying to make Ai and actually
have it do something useful in the
education space to get to an advanced
level quicker that's that's our goal
yeah well sounds good like it's a lovely
initiative certainly in your book uh you
talk a lot uh in existential physics a
scientist guide to Life's biggest
questions first chapter involves a lot
of discussions of the of of mathematics
and we we talked last time about your
you know beef with Max tag Mark that
what did you say um uh you said I
listened to it again you said max Max
tar believes reality is all mathematical
that's fine but it's not scientific but
in there you have wigner's famous quote
the unreasonable effectiveness of math
and the physical sciences and I've
changed that around I've changed it now
to say this is King's maximum now uh
King says uh the unreasonable
effectiveness of hype in the physical
sciences this past month you made
multiple videos about
lk99 about all these new and fusion
breakthroughs on on your Channel what is
going on why is hype so prevalent
nowadays and maybe we'll start with the
lk99 debacle what was your take we just
live through this maybe explain to
people what was claimed and if you think
it was justified the hype that was um
present both in the scientific circles
but mostly on Twitter the uh lk99 I
actually found this super exciting uh
you know it was such a lovely public
demonstration of how
scientists think and work you know they
were like okay this could be really
interesting let's try and do it and and
and everyone rushing to try to reproduce
the thing um and I I thought I thought
it was such a a lovely view inside
science that the public normally doesn't
get so this is why I talked about it
honestly I didn't really understand what
they were trying to explain in the paper
with their they had a particular theory
for why the thing would work uh and so
on but um in any case so um I I thought
that uh it really showcases why
scientists are in science you know
they're excited about this kind of thing
I wouldn't even count this as hype
because uh surprisingly enough most of
the major newspapers didn't didn't even
report on it right so this is I think
why my videos did so well exactly
because the standard media didn't uh
want to write about it
so I'm not sure that this is a good
example of hype uh there have been other
cases of hype you just you mentioned the
second one I've already forgotten uh
nuclear fusion what's that yeah the the
fusion results from late last year or
the earlier this year the earlier superc
conducting room temperature superc
conductivity uh claims and then we'll
get to some other other
claims to the but you I mean look at
what happened with the fusion thing so
the the first NF shot
you know was big news like national news
press release basically and then the
second one everyone was like oh yeah but
this the same thing theyve already done
previously right so no one wanted to
hear about it so I thought it was pretty
funny actually uh but yeah I mean
there's some there's some real promise
in that kind of thing and also I mean
when it comes to the N there's a lot of
national pride behind it of course which
which I understand so so this is why the
American newspapers make a big deal out
of it I can understand that so recently
I had the opportunity to go on uh Joe
Rogan Experience and that was kind of
predicated in some sense because of some
earlier hype that occurred this summer
uh which is when he kind of put out a
tweet based on a a single author uh
paper uh from the University of Ottawa
and it was uh by Professor Gupta there
and he had done some calculations and
claimed that he could reconcile the jwst
Galaxy um early Evolution population due
to a combination of uh an extend a
longer extended period extended age of
the universe and he claimed it was 26
billion years old and then Joe Rogan
tweeted this out and he said uh this
amazing to think that the universe is 26
billion years old twice as old as
scientists thought and I don't know why
like 26 would be more shocking than 13.8
but but anyway let's say it is and then
Elon Musk uh our friend and proprietor
of the xplatform he chimed in and said
yeah but you know to me Dark Matters the
more more sketchy or more sketch than
and this sent the Twitter verse into
apoplexia and they went nuts about both
of these guys what are they talking
about these Jokers and so I I talked
about this with Joe and I was on his
podcast and we'll put a link to that
somewhere in the notes but he um you
know he clearly is very interested in
this but do you know do these people
like musk and Rogan do they have an
obligation to not spread hype and if so
how do they know it's not hype I I I did
a podcast with Allison kpatrick who was
the victim last year she's a professor
in Kansas and this guy Eric learner had
put out a paper that said that the big
or he put out an I think maybe he even
appeared with him at the II Festival but
he said that the Big Bang never happened
and he's been saying this for 30 years
but last year it got a lot of attention
what do you make of this these
discussions about the age of the
universe and we cosmologist especially
people like me doing observation we
don't know what the hell we're doing um
first describe that did the big bang
happen Sabina is the universe 26 billion
years old or is it not well first of all
so this Eric uh what's his name lanaa
something like this uh whatever so I was
about to look at this and then I saw
that you made a great video about it and
I thought oh great Brian has done it so
I don't have to look at it you could
tell me when you're when you're proud of
me I would really like that
just send me yeah no I mean it was it
was a great video everyone should watch
it um yeah so and then I didn't really
have to think about it uh I thought I I
wrote something about this for Nautilus
magazine because part of the confusion
is that we use the word Big Bang to mean
three different things there are some
people who use the word Big Bang Theory
to describe everything that expands
basically uh and then there is like this
hypothetical first moment uh in in time
which we can debate whether it actually
happened or what it even means for
something like this to happen uh and if
we can ever figure out and I go on about
this in my book and then some people
actually use the Big Bang Theory to
specifically refer to Lambda CDM which
is even more restrictive I think part of
the reason people get confused about it
it's just because that we as scientists
uh use the word
confusingly uh when we talk to the
broader public like in in the literature
it's not an issue of course because if
people mean Lambda CDM they're right
Lambda CDM right so that was that uh
about uh the thing with the 26 years I
didn't even look at the paper you know I
I read the press release and I was like
okay there's this one guy who's written
a paper and he has some calculation God
knows you know do I even want to spend
my time look at it I mean there were
only so many hours in the day and
actually I I saw later that of course um
uh uh Dr Becky what's her name Rebecca
SM SM yeah exactly did a wonderful video
about it uh and so I was like yeah you
know of course people ask me a lot about
they but I'm
like you know have better things to do
and so I find it a little bit perplexing
actually that you you think that Joe and
and and musk and
so they should be able to figure out
that just because there's you know one
guy who who managed to publish a paper
in some Journal uh that says the
universe is tce as old as everybody else
said it doesn't mean it's actually true
right I mean these things happen yeah I
did a video with Alis and kpatrick
because she had done you know when the
when the jwc data came out she's an
expert in early Galaxy formation and
she's an observer she uses the web
telescope unlike me and she you know she
when the results first came out she has
quoted a nature saying something like
you know I'm in shock you know this just
throws my whole world into disarray or
something and then learner Ed that to
say you know cosmologist oh no she said
I I'm panicking at these results or
something and he used that as like Panic
you know people don't understand what's
going on or and uh and and so I had her
on and then she and I talked for you
know a while about it and we went
through thoroughly and and different um
different attributes and then the next
day S I get an email from uh from
Professor Gupta I should say learner's
not he's not a p he works on like fusion
and plasmas and he has his favorite
plasma cosmology wow I just heard some
plasma getting generated near you and
bod and v v b over there but Sabina uh
he wrote me Professor goop wrote me the
next day he's like uh and I was
expecting him you're an a-hole and how
dare you and I'm gonna sue you and
actually we'll talk about that from one
of your friends uh professor sarar in
just a second but anyway Gupta the
author of the 26 billion year he said
well you know I I thank you I still
think I'm right but but I I really
appreciate what you did and um you
should know that it's true my my my
media office at my campus was was the
one that really promoted it he didn't
want to like make this big splash and
they promoted it and it went to fizz.
org and then they just print anything
and then Joe Rogan finds it right so but
I wanted to ask like you are you know
kind of uh very comfortable talking
about heterodox ideas and in fact you
did a video with sairar
um who who really didn't like my first
book he he he really um but uh we we
don't here to talk about my favorite
subject which is me we're here to talk
about you and when subir Professor sarar
you know he is kind of iconic clastic
you know in that he saying things like
the cosmological principle doesn't hold
so how do you know you know if if
somebody is right you know like uh like
a sar car I assume you think he has he's
onto something the cosmological
principle may not be valid versus
someone like Gupta who's also a
professor and very brilliant person and
maybe you think this is not even worthy
of your time so how do you allocate your
attention that's your most precious
commodity right how do you know that SAR
car might be worth pursuing and and gupa
not for example well I don't know you
know it's just a totally biased
subjective uh opinion uh so I'm afraid I
have nothing intelligent to say about it
I would say that when it comes to the
cosmological principle like why would
anyone think that it's valid to begin
with like this is like literally an
assumption that we just put into the
model whereas you know the conclusion
that the universe is uh 13.8 billion
years old this is something that we
extracted uh from the data and yeah it
could be wrong uh certainly uh but uh
you know I wouldn't bet on it I guess um
I mean the cosmological principle comes
from people like Bondi and gold and and
you know hoil uh they coin that term in
kind of harmony with the capern
principle which I don't think you would
uh reject right so they called this the
perfect cosmological principle and and
that was a motivation behind the steady
state or what they call the Quasi steady
state universe in other words that um
that the Universe shouldn't really care
about where you are who you are or what
you are and that seems reasonable if you
are a capern so I guess that's why I
would sort of treat the capern prince
otherwise you have to say there's
something special about where we are who
we are what we are I suppose um but I'll
let you respond and we can move on after
this well so certainly that's like the
philosophical motivation for making this
assumption but in the end it's just a
mathematical assumption that we put into
the models uh and it might just be wrong
and so I mean there's always this
question like is the universe actually
homogeneous on this particular scale I
this is what it comes down to like uh
and which scale does the universe begin
to appear homogeneous on the average and
uh this is what what uh zuba is picking
out with his analysis so he's he's just
saying that look this assumption just
doesn't fit with the data and now the
issue is that if you throw out the
cosmological principle it becomes very
difficult to formulate mathematical
models as you certainly know uh right
basically all those cosmological
simulations and everything that we make
they kind of have this underlying
assumption that the cosmological
principle uh is good uh and if you don't
have that where you have to come up with
something else and some people are
trying and well we we'll see what comes
out of this it's not something that I
work on myself but I I think he's he's
making a good point I want to now pivot
to things that excite you that get you
interested as opposed to things that
annoy you um so which are the most you
know kind of recent 10 or so or five
maybe five newsletters and you should
all subscribe to her newsletter I get it
I love it every every Wednesday it it is
a little bit of sunshine to get me over
the hump of hump day here in America I
don't know if it comes out on Thursday
over there but uh anyway Sabina um you
detail all these great new discoveries
findings and stuff uh last
week wow all right Thor Thor has entered
the podcast hello Thor wow that was
powerful uh your or your m microphone is
really omnidirectional Sabine I was
asking you uh there was recently you had
a a really cute video you talked about
the bright wheeler process and you you
said I hope when they create matter from
light that they will say Let There Be
matter maybe you can say it in your
inimical voice uh but but Sabino of your
most recent few videos and newsletters
what things do you think will hope or
rather hope I want to say will hold up
and and be converted from you know
possible news to real news for what's
excites you the most recent I'm terribly
boring I'm going to go with Quantum
Computing uh I I think it's really
exciting and it's it's also it's like
super interesting to see uh how much
research there is and how quickly it's
moving forward um people are trying all
kinds of new approaches um as you
probably kept track of this a little bit
like uh there's now uh photonic Quantum
Computing uh is kind of moving forward
very nicely the uh topological Quantum
Computing is back on the radar
ironically enough you know it was this
weird thing that Microsoft was pursuing
that no one really believed would work
work out and then Google comes and says
you know we we made it work and everyone
was like oh wait what just happened so I
thought that was really interesting and
then I'm just uh literally I was just
trying to figure out earlier today
what's with the optical tweezers uh you
know there are people used to work on
the uh ion
traps um but the thing with the ions is
where they're charged uh and that brings
in a lot of problems so now PE people
are trying to use uh neutral atoms hold
in place with Optical tweezers and that
has some advantages and I'm trying to
figure out what's going on there that's
really exciting so I always joke that
you know uh quantum computers are really
good at you know solving the everyday
problem of you know the quantum LR Ian
for a many body system are they really
useful uh talk talk about some of their
applications and utility besides just
solving hamiltonians in quantum
mechanics as Fineman also mentioned many
years ago yeah well I don't know if you
saw this but um like one or two months
ago there was a big uh headline in the
New York Times about IBM showing Quantum
utility and you look at the paper and
what did they do it was the hang on if
you get this together the the trotz time
evolution of the
two-dimensional transverse field ising
model and so I'd say that this is not
exactly what the average person means by
utility so I mean don't get me wrong
it's like it's super cute paper you know
they actually you can you can just look
at the map of the cubits and you see oh
okay you know it's a it's a it's it's a
spin spin chain so it simulates itself
basically so and I can understand why
why the people are excited about it but
uh you know it's it's it's a far way of
uh being useful for any everyday
applications basically but certainly the
idea of quantum Computing is just based
on standard quantum mechanics which is a
very well confirmed Theory and so for me
I I I think it's is kind of a win-win
situation it's like either they get
quantum computers to work which will be
super exciting because then you can
suddenly solve certain kinds of problems
much faster than we currently can or
they don't work in which case there's
something more with quantum mechanics
which personally I would even find more
interesting yeah absolutely so then I
guess the other kind of side of this
coin is what would you say is like the
most annoying Trend in modern science is
there anything that provokes you or
irritates you most of all I know you're
you're known for being a you know very
opinionated German woman as it says with
with crazy hair I I don't know why they
say that but anyway uh Saina what annoys
you if anything about science the most
or reporting on science the most you
know science is a really broad subject
uh so uh I mean partly the issue comes
from the press releases like I find this
I find this just like really annoying
for my science news when I put them out
is that the press releases they often
completely lack the context like
everything is groundbreaking and new
even if it's this tiny incremental thing
you know it's some pimple on a huge
research field and then you you have to
do the footwork yourself to try and
figure out just exactly how much of this
had been done previously and more often
than not you find out well it's actually
not all that remarkable um and so it
just creates a lot of noise you know I
think there like 90 % of those press
releases shouldn't exist in the first
place it's like on a fish market where
everyone shouting my fish is the biggest
fish come and buy my fish so it's kind
of like this and it's really I haven't
really found a good way to filter the
stuff other than you're just looking at
every damn thing which Wast a lot of
time and yeah so I kind of basically I'm
the filter for other people now yes yeah
yes so I want to refer you have you ever
ever heard of the famous uh principle
known as brandolini's
law no I'm afraid not brandolini's law
is also known as the asymmetry
principle it asserts that the time and
energy to refute a false statement
particularly in the realm of complex
topics like science far exceeds the time
and energy needed to create and
disseminate that falsehood in the first
place therefore sabinaa the world is
full of unrefuted how do you react to
that principle I heard of this I just
didn't uh know the name um it's
certainly true if you look at what gets
published in physics I mean we've all
seen this uh right I mean there's just
stuff that uh is really really hard to
get rid of like uh one example that
Springs to my mind is the bullet cluster
myth that I've complained about
previously so the idea that the bullet
cluster uh rules out uh modified gravity
which uh has been debunked over and over
again um and actually if you if you look
at the paper like if you look at the
published literature uh they're not even
claiming this but people keep repeating
it anyway though in recent years it's
died down a little bit maybe I've
complained about it enough uh but um so
so those are like typical problems like
zombie problems or also since we were
talking about this previously um when um
Elon Musk saying that he's kind of skep
about Dark Matter it seems a little bit
sketchy I'm not sure he actually knows
what he's talking about uh and so a lot
of people who who who are not in
astrophysics have this kind of reaction
like they're just introducing some kind
of stuff that we can't see to make the
equations uh work out you know the only
thing I can say is that they've actually
thought about what they're doing a
little bit and if if you know what's
going on it actually does make a lot of
sense and I say this even though I'm not
a big fan of Dark Matter well you should
know that I actually cited you in
reference by a teaching committee a
teaching evaluation committee comes to
my cosmology class every year and they
want to check in on how good a teacher I
am and what kind of stuff I'm teaching
to my students so the H uh the full
Professor happens to be a string
theorist or high energy theorist came to
evaluate me and uh along with a Jun a
more Junior colleague and he liked the
lecture I think but then at the end he
sends me as a evaluation and he said in
your discussion for the evidence of dark
matter is there a reason you didn't
mention the bullet cluster and as if
that ruled it out in other words why did
I why did I talk about M and I didn't
mention the bullet cluster as disproving
mon so this is a full Professor a
brilliant you know scientist I cited
your uh your article in Scientific
American is dark matter real can put
that in the show notes uh and people
present it and he kept pushing back on
it a total a person and she he said I
don't know why Saina talks about the
bullet cluster as a statistical outlier
statistical questions of how often
galaxies Collide don't seem relevant at
all to the mass that they Collide and in
fact there are other uh things can you
say more about why isn't a good evidence
that dark matter behaves like matter
that just happens to interact without
themselves and I said it's not what
Sabina said it's what the authors say so
it it's uh talking about you know how
likely should you find a cluster like
the bullet cluster versus is how often
would you uh find that in mod but the
bigger question is you know they were
basically criticizing my pedagogy
because I didn't mention the bullet
cluster that's how pervasive this sort
of myth is about the bullet cluster but
as you know since we spoke last year I
had on morai mgram on the podcast and I
wouldn't say that he was my audience's
favorite I had on Stacy mcau also and we
talked about Mond um what would you say
the status is from someone who is very
interested and involved in this field uh
but it's not what you do dayto day but
uh tell me what is what would you say is
now you know kind of the status of M you
you seem to be more of a proponent of it
than ever almost well yeah I mean so is
it's difficult really like I changed my
mind on this uh every other week first
of all let me say I think it makes total
sense you wouldn't talk about the bullet
cluster because it's just not from what
the evidence is concerned it's just not
very conclusive one way or the other so
why talk about it now when it comes to
the question uh dark meta versus Mon as
you probably know we might have talked
about this previously that I've been
kind of bullish about Hybrid models uh
in particular superf fluid uh dark
matter which is in principle some kind
of particle but it condenses and then it
uh has a phase where it mimics modified
gravity and I've been very excited about
this for several years uh and I've been
working working about uh on this with um
well partly with Stacy and with uh tobas
M and we did a lot of analysis and in
the end it turned out not to work all
that well uh at least the model that we
looked at which is kind of the simplest
model that you can think of goes back to
Justin kurri and his collaborators it
has problems so you know it it doesn't
work with uh gravitational lensing and
has some other issues so now I'm less
optimistic about this kind of thing
doesn't completely rule out the idea um
basically I've I've more or less come to
the conclusion that it doesn't make a
lot of sense to take every single model
and then try to calculate every possible
single obser observable that you can
think of and try to see how well it fits
and so on because you can do this until
the end of time I'm hoping sooner or
later someone will uh train some uh
neuron Network feed it with all the data
and there's a question like is there
even enough data but in principle I
think you could do it and spit out some
kind of equations and we'll just see
what kind of equation it is and I would
guess uh but you know this is again my
my personal bias that it'll turn out to
be some kind of mixture of both uh m in
certain regimes and more like the code
dark matter because that seems to work
very well in other regimes my thumb is
very busy right now holding up good old
Albert but if yours is free please go
ahead and hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm Sabina as an
experimentalist I have to tell you I
have to stand up for my experimental
friends we studied nothing all the time
and then sometimes nothing becomes
something and this has happened recently
in many many varieties hasn't happened
necessarily in in a dark matter uh this
not to say it couldn't but you know we
put out papers and we study things like
axons and dark photons and uh
particulate dark matter all the time and
just you know when I grew up as a young
you know PhD student it was said to me
by the eminent one of the fathers of
inflation I'll just say that one of the
father that we'd never detect the
polarization of the CMB not not just
this the B modes which could be true we
never and in fact we had many upper
limits my my PhD thesis was an upper
limit and so if you were around tweeting
in 1999 2000 you would have said Brian
keing thesis came out more nothing
there's no iation of the CNB but these
are important it's important to have
upper limits because not not only
because sometimes they lead to
detections uh but but also because they
really are doing what a what an
experimentalist job is which is to prove
theorists wrong I wonder if you can
explain like when you when you have
these tweets these snarky tweets uh what
what exactly is going through your mind
would you Advocate that we shouldn't be
you know building these bigger and
bigger Dark Matter detectors or CMB
polarimeters in my case what would you
say what what is the meaning of of uh of
what an experimentalist should be doing
in your opinion well so first of all I I
write these tweets not because I intend
some Grant message it's just a brief
summary of what's in the thing so in by
way of saf your click okay so so this is
what it says it happens frequently
people read way too much into my tweets
but yeah I guess you're familiar with
that problem I've said this many times
before I just think it's not a
particularly good straty to go and hunt
for every damn particle that theorists
come up with because there are
infinitely many of those so I'm not
surprised that all those experiments
come back finding nothing uh because I'm
not blaming the experimentalists they're
doing exactly what they should be doing
blaming the theorist for making up all
those particles in the first place but
it's kind of it's you know it's the
cycle it goes around because the
theorists can justify their work because
there are those experiments you know
they can look for this with this
experiment at this lab and then on the
other hand the experimentalist justify
uh their experiment with with uh the
theory because that there's this guy who
thought up this kind of particle which
has exactly this kind of interaction
that we can measure in our experiment
isn't that great and so then they make
the experiment they don't find the
particle because there wasn't any reason
for it to exist in the first place I
don't have a big problem with
experimentalists who just like to
measure things and try to figure out if
there's something there in in in a new
parameter range
just look at the result you know it's
not going anywhere right yeah for things
like axons and and dark photons and all
sorts of industrial strength you know
theoretical campaigns I agree there
should be some kind of moratorium at
some level uh but uh it it does seem
like the number of people that do these
types of experiments is far smaller than
the number of you know NBA players here
or you know football munchin Baron
munchin uh football in over there in
Germany so these are very small you know
cohorts of people and I guess you know
from the perspective of trying to do
something that's never been done it's
something I think we should do what what
people in in the stock market do which
is to hedge in other words I think
experimentalists should should have on
their portfolio something that's really
ambitious that might not exist like a
dark Photon but they should also be
doing stuff simultaneously if possible
that is guaranteed signs so for example
we look for B mode polarization which
would be the harbinger the imperator of
inflationary primordial pertubations
right and so that might not be there at
all they may be at a very low level
inflation may not have happened
inflation May produce a be mode Spectrum
that's IM you know unmeasurable uh but
we also can look for things like the
mass of neutrinos which is a form of
dark matter that exists we know it
exists um and we know we have the
sensitivity to measure its mass are the
two of the three neutrinos that may have
mass with the exact same instrumentation
so therefore we're doing something
guaranteed to work and something that
might work and if it does it might be
the biggest discovery of you know many
many years so anyway that's my
perspective as an experimentalist that
you know we should not be looking to
prove these theories but we should be
looking for win-win outcomes that we get
a result out no matter what the uh the
nature happens to hand to us but uh it's
getting late there Sabina but I have a
million audience questions I just wanted
to ask a quick one about your latest
video which is very touching on the
global Mental Health crisis I mean you
do stuff on trans athlete H you you do
you do you know this two plus two really
five uh you are not afraid you're very
courageous person uh you're not afraid
to take on controversial topics but this
one was not controversial but I was
curious what caused you to pursue you
know a video an in-depth video about the
global Mental Health crisis well I was
trying to figure out if there really is
one you know whatever happened to you
know all this talk about how the coid
pandemic has damaged uh mental health
and I I read conflicting things about it
you know there there were like big
headlines saying oh we have a global
Mental Health crisis and then I read
some papers which I mentioned in the
video that said well actually the word
went through the pandemic reasonably
well and we didn't see any big
difference in uh mental health before
and after and so I was like so so now
which one is it
right yeah and I thought it's probably
interesting not just for me but for
other people as well uh and so this is
why uh we made the video very good it's
a great service and do you think that in
particular academics like you and me
that we should pay attention to any
signs aside from coid and the stress
that that definitely did put do you
think that there are uh special kind of
um ways that that academics can handle
the stress of Academia you rattled off
early or you know a whole list of things
that academics are expected to do what
do you think is your top piece of advice
for young people we have a huge audience
of young people that listen to this
podcast so U please tell me what would
you give advice to them uh to do to you
know take care of their giant brains and
their mental health well first of all I
would say don't be afraid to ask for
help there are actually luckily a lot of
universities have places where you can
ask for counseling for students uh in
particular and they'll be happy to help
in MO most cas I guess because they
they're aware that these problems exist
especially in young people who are more
susceptible to mental health problems I
think partly the problems that we see
especially among young academics they're
just baked into the system which is
exploiting Young brains often for
miserable conditions like I guess we've
all been there at some point you know
you you stuck at some kind of job that
doesn't even pay for the rent uh what he
supposed to do uh it becomes very
stressful uh and you're not getting
anywhere with your thesis that kind of
stuff and your your supervisor is always
away it doesn't listen to you it doesn't
really understand you your parents are
constantly asking like how's he going
with your stupid thesis and and yeah so
it's just the situation is not very good
and
um you know I I don't have any great
insights other than you know watch out
for your physical health in the first
place you know do some other things
don't get stuck on that one thing watch
out for your friends stay in touch with
your relatives if you still have any uh
and so on there are other things in life
that are important not just that you
finish your your thesis yeah finding the
work life balance you know and uh but
you know fortunately young people have
you know the Gift of Health and you know
they're time billionaires they're
they're going to live a lot longer and
uh they're life is more than just the
you know the PHD but I was there you
know I wanted to be get my PhD and be
called the doctor and you know start
prescribing medication no I don't do
that can you explain when people talk
about as Joe Rogan asked me about this
week you know what does it mean oh they
described a mysterious new Force so what
is the G minus 2 and how how does it
potentially imply new forces and uh new
fields in in any case I actually think
this is a fairly recent Trend like
within the past five years or something
that the media has picked up this phrase
the fifth Force which sounds like really
mysterious but normally what they mean
is like it's some kind of new particle
maybe or maybe something else and we
don't know what it is so the G minus 2
that's uh the Magnetic Moment of the
muon or actually the Magnetic Moment of
the muon minus two which is where the
minus two comes from because if you
don't take into account the full Quantum
effects uh it should be two and then all
those Quantum effects go to top of it so
so this is kind of the interesting
contribution and you can calculate the
Magnetic Moment of the MU and G minus 2
from the standard model and so it's a
difficult calculation it gives you one
result and then you can go and measure
it and now the problem is that the
result of the measurement doesn't agree
with the calculation and this is
actually this isn't new um this anomaly
has been around in physics for pretty
much as long as I have so for for 20
years or something um 2001 or two some
around that time it was first measured
at Brook Haven but the significance was
3.5 or I don't know and and then at
formula they repeated the measurement
but with a higher precision and it
increased to 4.1 Sigma and now it's uh I
forgot something like five Sigma or
something if you take like the previous
value of this calculation and so so this
is where the problems begin because as I
said it's a calculation and some people
say that actually the problem is with
the standard model calculation we're not
doing it right and then there are other
groups which uh get slightly different
results that are more compatible with
the measurement I think what's clear at
this point is that the culprit is not
the measurement I mean at least this is
what I would say you know I'm I'm a
theorist but on this uh count I have
full trust that the experimentalists
know what they're doing like this you
know two different experiments basically
find the same thing that looks pretty
sound to me so then the question is like
what's going on is it that we don't
understand how to do a calculation in
the standard model or is the problem
actually the standard model and we need
to add something new could be for
example new particles which um heavier
particles than the LHC could produce
which the G minus 2 might be sensitive
to or it could be something else
entirely you know some other kind of new
physics that you might call A fifth
Force but I personally I don't find this
a particularly useful term oh yeah and
if those are interested in seeing
sabina's guns she did a video called the
fifth Force where she's flexing her
bicep my great
bicep I love itth okay saben we've
reached the uh portion of the episode
where we ask audience questions if you
have five 10 more minutes I would love
it uh my audience is so tickled and
stoked that you're on and I posted a
question you know to the audience what
questions would you like Saina to answer
and just a reminder you can always ask
me questions for me to ask my guests uh
Dr Brian keing on YouTube Twitter
Instagram uh threads uh are you on
threads I tried but I couldn't it said
it's not available in your country or
something at least that was the case
when I looked the last time soe yeah
it's just to too annoying to have to
there just be one Mega app and uh you
know Zuck and and Elon can fight out you
know who gets the uh the money from it
but anyway somebody wrote back Dez oxen
one of my viewers on YouTube wrote damn
dude everything is good you're just
crushing it and kicking off bucket items
because this week I was on Rogan and now
I'm talking to Sabina so here we go
we're going to talk about questions from
the audience very first one comes from
Marius nabal she says sabina's channel
is very informative and entertaining it
is also insanely humorous for the
attentive and quick witted question how
does she come up with those rapid fire
comic twist that punctuate her videos
including her magic telephone the magic
telephone it was my
idea so what happened was that I I
bought this desk which you see and I was
thinking I have to put something on it
it just looks too boring and so I
thought I put a plant on it but I
couldn't find a good plant and so I went
into the children's room and I saw this
red telephone and I was like that's it
I'm going to take the red telephone and
then I was like okay so but I got to do
something with the damn telephone right
and and so this is where I came from so
um I've been working with several joke
writers it kind of works so so I
actually do most of the jokes myself
because for the most part I found that
I'm funnier than the joke writer but I
do take some inspiration uh from other
people um every once in a why I'm I
guess I'm a little peculiar about it
hell's Gator as would like to know if
Sabina if she got the funds to do any
science project she wanted what would it
be and why well I would really like to
test um do specific tests on the
measurement process in quantum mechanics
so because I'm convinced that there is
something that we really don't
understand uh in the foundations of uh
quantum mechanics that concerns the
measurement process and I think it can
be experimentally tested and it would
open a complete completely new Avenue to
Quantum Technologies unfortunately no
one wants to give me the money so yeah
so the great
breakthrough we'll have to wait well we
we're gonna be working with sir Roger
Penrose here and James tag and others on
a on a Quantum uh Quantum measurement
problem experiment that you're more than
welcome to be our theoretical advisor
and uh tell tell sir Roger what's going
on I'll keep you posted about that Andre
M uh asks uh solutions to the fery
Paradox uh Sabina how do you solve
ferm's Paradox and first state what it
is and then State your favorite solution
to it Paradox where are all the
extraterrestrials why haven't we found
them uh well I think we're just too
boring They Don't Care About Us they
they don't care contacting us you know I
think about it basically like we think
about insects you know they are like
okay so I'm not a zoologist I don't know
don't ask me uh 500 million species of
insects most of which we've never heard
about and most of us couldn't care less
like you know there's one more species
of uh I don't know grasshoppers we're
not going to look for them uh and and so
um I think this quite plausibly explains
why uh aliens haven't contacted us the
other thing that I like to point out is
if there's any way to communicate faster
than the speed of light this is almost
certainly what aliens are using and
since we haven't figured out how to
communicate faster than the speed of
light we we probably can't hook into
their communication channels so really
what we should be doing if you want to
communicate with aliens is we should try
to figure out how to communicate faster
than the speed of light uh which I think
is possible but that's a completely
different story very good okay and this
one comes from Twitter and you can
follow Sabina of course on Twitter as
well SK DH are those your
initials yes I never asked you what what
does the uh K and d stand for
kis Sab
keld John tis uh writes have you read
Skin Walkers at the Pentagon which is a
book about aliens but I want to ask you
a question instead um do you think what
do you make of the recent you know
Congressional testimony and statements
by past guest Ryan Graves a fighter
pilot on this podcast and David grou who
claims that the pentagon or the um the
US government is concealing evidence of
the existence of
nonhuman biological material presumably
recovered from a crashed UAP how does
your mind wrap around this I don't know
anything why you asking
me you know what would I know about
existent question it's an existential
question yeah I don't know I mean people
have all kinds of weird ideas about all
kinds of things so God knows what's
going on there okay again on Twitter the
artist formerly known this is his name
how would you feel about a new particle
being discovered and named the gobble
theg well as my editor points out it's a
terrible word uh it's long and it's
clunky and so I think the God particle
is actually a much better name but uh
then someone has already tried to use
that I think I know the answer to this
from j e my wand is the Multiverse idea
a gobble if yes how come NE nature
favors existence over non-existence
first of all I don't think the multivers
answers that question but also I
wouldn't call it gobbledigook um it's
just I wouldn't call it a scientific
hypothesis it's more a philosophical
idea so you you can believe it if you
want to uh but since you can't actually
measure anything in those other
universes I don't think it's scientific
okay last question from Twitter there's
many more we could be here all night and
it's by dinosaur K uh who asks why do
you hate free will like Sam Harris who
has become
nuts I don't hate Free Will I don't know
where people get this from I actually go
on about this in my book which I think
is a fairly nuanced approach free world
is just not it's not an idea that makes
any sense to me I don't know what people
even mean by it but you know I see the
people very interested talking about the
topic and so naturally I write about it
and make videos about it be because
people watch them so so if everyone
stopped talking about Free Will i' I'd
also stop talking about it okay last one
uh this is from back on my YouTube
channel
korim 43 which I almost chose for my one
of my kids names uh is the Everett
quantum mechanical view the same as
predeterminism and then he or she asks
should every Branch need to exist
already you want to say something you do
of course cover in existential physics
you cover um everettian physics but I
get the sense it's not your favorite
interpretation so and can you say a
little bit about Everett and then why or
why not uh you you choose to think of it
as in the way that you do so I don't
know exactly what the person meant with
pred deterministic uh possibly they
meant super deterministic in which case
the answer is know it's a different
thing uh so super determinism is not an
interpretation of quantum mechanics it's
actually a modification it's a different
kind of theory it's actually more
similar to a penrose's collapse models
but I digress so the the aate
interpretation um no I'm I'm not a fan
of that because I don't think it solves
any problem I don't have a big issue
with it you know if people want to
interpret the mathematics that way
that's fine with me but I don't really
see what you gain from it okay Sabina
and we've reached the uh end of the
conversation I could go on for hours
with you but you're already braving a
headache and a thunderstorm and that's
been just lovely chatting with you I'll
ask you one of my final four questions
which come from Sir Arthur C Clark's
famous quips and this one is one of the
uh favorites that I've really latched on
to lately I like to bring it out on my
colleagues he says uh he said the f when
an elderly but distinguished scientist
says something is possible he or she is
very likely to be right but when he says
something is impossible he or she is
very likely to be wrong I want to use
that to ask you a question what have you
changed your mind about recently what
have you been wrong about if anything
and how would you uh how would you
respond to Sir arthury Clark's quip I
already said that I've changed my mind
about the feasibility of those hybrid
meta models uh right which which I'd
been quite excited about for some years
and I talked about this WR papers about
it that would be the first thing that
Springs to my mind um I I think it's
broadly speaking I like this quote a lot
uh because um I I think that we dismiss
too many things as Impossible Too
Quickly for example the possibility to
communicate faster than the speed of
light I think we're throwing this out
too easily and it would deserve some
more thought very good Dr Saina
hossenfelder
proprietor of the channel by the same
name now at 1 million subscribers just
an enormous accomplishment uh for
someone who aspires with the logarithm
of your number of followers uh and the
author of many books lost in math and
more recently in paperback existential
physics a scientist guide to Life's
biggest questions and I urge you to read
the warning warning in this book because
uh because it will make you think and
sometimes you know uh as I always say to
my kids thinking makes my head hurt uh
but you want to be careful because uh
these are questions on which science can
finally have some applicability that was
previously purely philosophical so
Sabine I want to congratulate you on
your great success I wish you much more
to the stars and uh I hope we can chat
again thank you good to talk to you